here with more reaction to joe biden's
failures his reckless abandonment of
americans his never-ending blame game
he's the author of a massive bestseller
now a million sold american marxism now
the seventh straight week in a row
number one mark just told me uh he's the
host of life liberty levin and
nationally syndicated radio house and
also one of my best friends great one
you know
i say at the end of this show mark i say
let not your heart be troubled my heart
is aching and and i have like a five
alarm fire all these alarms going off of
my head
about how dangerous this is for hundreds
and hundreds of our fellow americans the
exact number of which nobody knows where
they are nobody knows and all of it
completely preventable and unnecessary
this president abandoned the mark he
abandoned our fellow americans
first i want to talk to general
milley
general milley i have this hanging on my
office hall you know who this is
this is george s patton
you're no george's patton general milly
how many anne franks are there tonight
in afghanistan how many anne franks
are hiding in cellars all across that
country today i want to talk about the
people left behind
not the 124 000 who've been evacuated to
safety i want to talk about the millions
who now have had genocide unleashed upon
them
and before joe biden became president
the united states were living mostly in
peace
and mostly in safety in what was a
neutralized afghanistan with a minimal
american military footprint
i want to read something i never do this
i went back to dwight eisenhower's book
crusade in europe
when he went to the death camps
he said the same day april 12 1945 i saw
my first horror camp
it was near the town of gotha
i've never felt able to describe my
emotional reactions when i first came
face to face with the indisputable
evidence
of nazi brutality against the jews and
ruthless disregard of every shred of
decency
up to that time i had known about it
only generally or through secondary
sources
i am certain however that i have never
at any other time experienced an equal
sense of shock
i visited every nook and cranny of the
camp because i felt it my duty to be in
a position from then on to testify at
hand
about these things in case these ever
grew up at home the belief or assumption
that the stories of nazi brutality were
just propaganda
some members of the visiting party were
unable to go through with the ordeal i
not only did so but as soon as i
returned to patins headquarters that
evening i sent communications to both
washington and london
urging the two governments to send
instantly to germany a random group of
newspaper editors and representative
groups from the national legislatures
i felt the evidence should be
immediately placed before the american
and british publics in a fashion that
would leave no room no room for cynical
doubt
now we have propagandists in this
country from the defense department to
the state department to the white house
highly paid admiral kirby
nick price
jenn pasake and others
and now generals who are part of the
propaganda
do you think george patton or omar
bradley or
the top general george marshall
would leave american citizens in enemy
territory under any circumstances or
conditions
including at the order the
commander-in-chief no commander-in-chief
has ever ordered any general
to leave citizens behind
what about these children and these
women
what about the afghan allies the men who
fought next to us fire fight after fire
fight
what about the 80 to a 100 000 siv visas
granted special visas granted to
patriots who fought side by side with
americans
instead we hear that the american
citizens didn't act fast enough instead
we hear this was a massive success
instead we hear we will use diplomacy to
deal with these nazis
instead we hear we may in the future
work with them against isis as if
they're different it's the taliban that
allowed al qaeda to attack us on 9 11.
the taliban
they have our equipment they have our
people they have our allies they are
going to threaten us they're working
with the communist chinese they're
working with putin they're working with
the iranians and listen to me america
can you hear the screams of the people
of afghanistan tonight
because they're screaming
can you hear the women being brutalized
can you hear the bullets and the
execution because it's occurring under
the cover of dark because our media is
unable to be there
while they're celebrating at the state
department and the defense department
and at the white house and while they
want to turn the corner and change the
politics the human infrastructure of all
things and to cover 19.
by god
i've never been more
disgusted with my government and the top
brass of the united states military than
i am right now listen
they're screaming do you hear them
they're begging for health do you hear
them american citizens they say waited
too long
waited too long
while joe biden lied to us over and over
and over again
this is a humiliation for our country it
is part of our history that can never be
wiped away and i feel so horrible for
our american troops our real soldiers
who would not have tolerated this
but for general austin and general
milley and all the rest of them and most
of all
joe biden you are blood on the hands for
the rest of your life that's it i'm done
a great one mark levine
don't forget mark show life liberty
levin sunday night right here on fox hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else